OOP oh oh I shouldn't be in this river
this is a bad river to be in um oh
that's a lot of Crocs and them some
Crocs
okay then hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to read
through it ever doodoo oh that's not
good that's that's what we call not good
hang on wait wait wait I'm just trying
to live man I'm just trying to live okay
all right then
forget that happened because that wasn't
supposed to happen at all and number two
ah there I am where's my hat every
single goddamn time I lose my goddamn
hat and every single goddamn time I'm
crossing this river I don't care what
y'all say I'm gonna put across here I
don't care how scary you think you is
gonna be me okay I'm taking shortcuts
and you horsey swoopy you're just gonna
have to suck it up and deal with it
okay that was will alright so we're
gonna move our way north because we need
to deal with the Native Americans that
are trying to get some help from the
government but oddly enough the
government in the 18th and 1900s not
being too very helpful in fact being
excessively harmful so let's see what we
can do about it
I forget what even they asked me to do
it's not like it's been forever although
judging by my new haircut which yes I
got a new haircut I might have been
years for all I know but I'm intent to
finish this game if anyone was curious
as far as the progress we've got going
we are apparently 46% done but I think
that's just because I haven't done too
many of the side quests which may or may
not have something to do with the store
then again maybe I have maybe I've done
so much at the syquest because I've done
pretty much everything the game has
asked me to do but that's mostly just
because I really like the game the
game's super duper fondness and I you
know when I say super duper you mean uh
you know I mean it hey how you doing hey
how you doing hey hello
you need suck poison suck poison oh my
god suck poison its suck poison time you
won't believe it it happened again it's
real deep yeah well don't you worry
about me I already got a stiff one for
tonight after that so funny that's so
funny every time I hear someone cry for
help I'm just gonna automatically go
into suck mode I mean ordinarily I'd
default the blow mode but when it comes
down to helping people in the wild wild
west I guess I got a cut engaging more
sucking than I anticipated anyway what
are we talking about something important
that we were doing but I can't even
remember what that is now so I'm just
gonna skip out on my way up north
in his beautiful beautiful country
somehow we just left the bayous how we
did that oh yeah I might want it over
here or is this just the edge of the
area where I was now cuz I killed like a
hundred people on the way out of that
trolley station and also we blew up the
trolley and also we ruined the town we
ruined pretty much everything in there
how are they gonna be happy with us the
answer is that they're probably not your
lucky day it's your lucky day you're
lucky I don't actually need money man
before it was like it was a gold mine
hunting of animals but then again it was
a lot easier to get the animal pelts
back to the town so they'd have to
actually carry them on my horse maybe
for the big ones you did I can't quite
remember what is going on here whoa whoa
oh it's just a grave okay weird oh
there's a D and what's this D is this
important or is this nothing
where's the d DS back there but I was
just there
Dutch vanderlin what does he want Dutch
needs to speak with me I don't like the
look of that Gator but it's just gonna
have to wait because we got something
else in store for us why would we do
that
yes do you need some sucked
[Music]
sorry listen you that wasn't a warning
you shot me
are you aimed your gun at me anyway
guess there's not much to be done about
it listen that wasn't that bad that guy
that guy tried to that guy tried to mess
with me anyway she won't be let's not
let's not worry about that Whoopie we
got a guy out here let me get let me
give him some get my horse some
tranquilizers here some some stimulants
everybody go easy as I inject you with
this horrible horrible concoction of
cocaine crack and heroin some uppers and
some Downers and a mixture of adderall
to really get you going and some ritalin
to really mellow you out and then I got
like alcohol in there just uh keep it
all nice and even and then I got some
then I got some viagra for later
that's not for you horsie that's for me
I need a stiff one tonight you heard
what my friend over there said what he
said was very true am I going all the
way back to wait a minute we're not
going am I going all the way back to
vanilla town virtuoso Van Alen vanderlin
[Music]
maybe maybe it is maybe it's not are you
always right here sir help a blind man
give you a dollar okay sure I got plenty
of dollars definitely hard-earned last
we spoke you didn't run far enough
oh okay all right thank you for that
thank you for the ominous messaging I
really appreciate that very helpful very
helpful indeed all right come on horsey
we got to go is that where I'm going I'm
right outside Volante doodle dam vaginal
what was it called
who is the damn place called voodoo
voodoo town
hello I'm here Kurt hey what's up hey
you doing hey how you doing hey how you
doing hey good see hi how you doing hey
how you doing all right okay okay no
wood there's a foreman his name is Dan
Murray mmm is the files in the office
above the refinery room it's that window
with the blind drawing up see if the
files are as incriminating as we believe
mr. Cornwall's men will destroy them if
they know you're coming there's only one
omission I don't intend for them to know
I'm coming
what were the files say the beer report
from Leyland oil development company and
you got the money
yes any ideas how I sneaked into this
place you could crawl under the fence or
hide in a wagon
they keep rolling in I'll go take a look
if there's a problem call from me I
thought the whole point was that this
had nothing to do with you ideally oh
[Laughter]
I'm quick all right activate bear
stealthy speed okay all right hang on
just got up there why square y square
why wouldn't it be triangle Oh
because I gotta activate the cinematic
camera okay all right you got it sneaky
sneaky like nobody's gonna know I'm in
the back of this wagon the long as I
keep it nice and stealthy ain't nobody
gonna know that's what I'm all about
this is healthy sneakiness why didn't it
start raining why is it pissed yellow
rain why is it more of a poop rain going
on here
I thought we didn't have pollution the
Industrial Revolution hasn't happened
yet why is it pooping from the sky oh
that's better
a nice somber blue so who's this
Cornwall guy I mean I know it's some
rich oil baron type but you got to do
something about it eventually and we
just made so many enemies we got like
the gooble wobbles
pulmo Driscoll's we got the old
Driscoll's then we got Cornwall and then
we got the Pinkertons against us it's
got too many oh yeah they're never gonna
knows me
activate bear camouflage ain't nobody
gonna know just casually leading it here
it's not even like a it's not even like
a drape over me all right whatever I
guess I should know I can't hop out
can't hop out where am i hopping out to
you gonna alright well here I go
lovey dude nudity day here we go sneaky
back activate bear lockpick ooh oh I
didn't wanna go I didn't want to go up
this way but I didn't realize is it's
gonna out of it
oh good there's way over there maybe if
I what excuse what what what what the
[ __ ] happened destroyed the die went
down one step who's that alright I guess
I can't do that then that's too noisy
I'm guessing is the problem there oh you
gotta be [ __ ] with me oh you're
[ __ ] me
oh you're [ __ ] me what the dick oh
come on
oh you big dick okay well I'll be right
back I guess nobody left for nobody
there's the sneaky bear myself
oops cinematic sneaking
well let's not do that cuz I don't want
to have to risk it again
okay we're not gonna go up the ladder
I'm not gonna go up the ladder we're
gonna sneak in oh not that way okay not
that way he's gonna go down how about
the downstairs one is that gonna be good
oh it's already open for me okay cover
transition not what I was expecting
all right
we just got up you that guys coming by
over there that's fine that's so fine
it's good a leader leader leader leader
literally do
okay yeah good thing this bear knows how
to sneak good thing this bear knows how
to not get caught no one's gonna find
this bear no one's gonna know this bear
no one's gonna even smell this bear this
bevit washing hey what are you doing man
you're looking out the window oh what a
terrible pastime you need to get a
better hobby dude I'm guessing it's a
big one marked office that's glowing all
brightly like oh well time for a beating
for long range does that seem important
right now
no beautiful by the Leyland oil
development company the one about the
oil near what PT I damn very sink mind
is a terrible thing to lose where where
is it oh I guess that's why I got
destroyed cuz that's the window right
outside of this office I'll take that if
you screw your trashcan I'm sorry I
don't mean to be understood tell the
guard yes it's just I'm working boss
fine
now stay quiet my head office will send
me back to get you hey you wouldn't want
head office to be worried about you now
no would you no no I think this bear is
part of a bear shooty shooty oh-ho boy
okay all right all right okay I I think
I just pried just best to run I don't
even need to kill him
I need a wolf and sorry you you
unfortunately we're in the wrong place
at the wrong time oh oh I see
god damn it come on come on oh god oh
god okay I gotta get it maybe it wasn't
the best idea just to run no I'm not
dead activate bear running away reflexes
activate bear jump loop bear hurdling
troll be my faithful steed yeah let's
get the hell out of here oh come on
won't be get it together smooth will
Steen get it together oh I thought you
were dead
okay go go go ghost will be going Scooby
ghost will be go activate swoopy speed
okay hey dude
they're not you know yeah I got it I got
it I gotta eat some man I'm hungry guys
canned ham stuff I'm sorry oh sorry that
was the horse not what I was aiming for
you don't see any more of them I mean I
see a lot of bullets I see a bullet hole
in the buddish won't be over here almost
not quite though I thought you wasn't
getting involved thank you we're gonna
enter and leave silently thank you you
saved my life
thank you I hope well I don't know what
I hope but who knows maybe these will be
of some use
here's your money mm good one thank you
I like this money it's real good
now there's got to be some benefit to
helping them oh that's some good money
now there's got to be some benefit to
helping them in the long term like maybe
they're gonna help me down the road yeah
but I don't know it's hard to say I'm
close enough to finish off this quest
with all the black Bell and all those
people the people that don't matter and
then black Bell him close enough to
finish that quest off so I'm gonna do
exactly that can you won't big go
haysoms won't be come on I mean I am
patty picking the path right among the
rocks yeah but I really hope they were
gonna see black
already see every night I think of the
backfill the time that we shared
together oh come on
that wasn't even a that wasn't even a
good one
that wasn't even a satisfying fall come
on
maybe someday I'll learn to actually
stick to the roads and probably not here
we go and almost beefed it again all
right come on
vanilla Valentine virtuoso Nespresso
what was it called I know you remember
goddamn it going back to the oil rig
thing or no is that is that Valentine I
have no idea wait I'm not even looking
for Valentine hang on I'm about to fall
and die but that's right I wasn't even
pointing in the right direction
jimboy Callaway that's it I'm going
there all right and three two one we
made it come on all the tracks please do
some rides whoopee I mean obviously I'm
the one navigating this on the one not
doing anything right in the first place
but I'm gonna blame you EP because I got
nothing else to do with my life
thank you lightning that was very
helpful a little a little horse cocaine
ought to do it for you schmoopy
there we go feeling better already this
rain is cool all right it's 2:40 a.m. I
don't even know if this mission is gonna
be available but I do know that I can
take the railroad back down
whenever I get it done hello hello drunk
boy Calloway this bars got bullet marks
to remember him by last I heard they was
in San Denis had rubes on a riverboat
there San Denis okay okay then I guess
I'll just go down to San Dena all right
whatever I gotta I gotta sleep till
morning so I gotta go to the hotel maybe
I can get me a bath again finally be
able to wash that I'd be awfully nice
bears need baths too you know I'm gonna
wash up I'm gonna sleep up actually
that's awfully rude hey dude Meister can
I get a room please head on up up up
down where am I supposed to go up is it
up or down
[Music]
I don't know I don't even know why I
tried to open the door there ah perfect
okay perfect all right let's go to
beddy-bye search drawer what's in the
drawer
nothing oh my god just go to bed already
don't close the drawer why are you
worried about closing the door go to bed
look at the bed go to bed go to don't
change your go to bed there we go
lay your head there larry lay your weary
bare head to rest and let's get on with
our lives we got places to be
we got things to see let's go go go go
go come on like you're not in a hurry at
all we gotta go go go go go life is
waiting for us as you're being a big old
dick come on let's go let's go let's go
come on
oh yeah real slow right yeah real slow
real slow I like it real slow come on
hurry up yeah all this not running
inside nonsense it's just ridiculous
like what kind of realism are we going
for here in gta5 you could sprint any
which away inside outside maybe you
couldn't sorry that was not assault that
was not assault yeah oh pardon yeah you
better be sorry all right that's what I
keep saying I got places to be - I would
ride my horse on the horse isn't here
some horse is not being helpful I'm
whistling but there ain't no person or
horse anybody Please Please Please
Please Please Please Please Please horse
horse horse horse no okay we're not
gonna get a horse I'm just gonna get
train tickets Antony
oh now you're here shrimpy thank you
just in time to not even matter
Oh wrong side again like always hey I
need to go to nine I need to go in a
hurry please hurry hurry hurry and we're
here so let's get going okay we're
already insane to know so we might as
well go see that riverboat if that's
gonna be even be
and then we can go see Dutch van der
Linde wants to have a word with us
whatever that means
what did i do what did i do I didn't
even do nothing to you all right where
are you at swampy she won't be you
causing problem one causing ruckus over
here won't be though that's you won't be
hey won't be can I hop up on you old boy
oh okay that's another way to do that
alright I need to go this way but I need
to not get hit by this not get hit get
hit by this train you need to get out of
the way oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
where am I I just I'm trying to find my
way to the river boat sorry I don't know
how I got over here I'm just trying to
find my way to the river boat Sorry
Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry
Sorry Sorry navigation here is real
sticky what are you doing she won't be
just go where I'm supposed to put yeah
good catch will be you're causing
problems no matter which way you go
right here we go now Jim boy Calloway is
gonna be on this boat that I just happen
to rob up hello hello
and a book about him this the riverboat
they're staying up yes sir they're here
well this I'm mr. Callaway usually
enjoying a drink on the observation deck
oh oh you're so helpful you can follow
me oh you're so nice you're so nice how
did you get on about how you'd expect
any good anecdotes anecdotes from the
old days to be honest things went a
little differently I killed three of the
four of them people yes that'll be fine
do you think anyone noticed it was you
noticed I think the people I shot
noticed I mean do you think anyone would
mind if I if we said he'd done it boy
Calloway sure I don't care just as long
as you share the money of course I will
literature is a filthy business but
sometimes it pays well
especially when you lie great that's a
goddamn nothing just grass me you know I
don't know have you been being me I'm
nobody buddy I'm somebody and I can't
have any nobody being this somebody you
god damn you I don't know what the
goddamn you are but just bear it ain't
nothing I wanna be so you can't be me
couldn't even be a bear what I can't
take credit for that which I dem says I
didn't I I'm an old man yes never have
no killing stuff going there Caesar he
can't happen to me I will kill both here
come
[Laughter]
you know buddy no of course you don't
but maybe you need to prove something
do you wisdom you've got quite a way
with words
maybe you should write my book and we
should kill Fred oh yeah let's no now
come on who shall we kill you kill me
yeah my slay my dragons years ago I
retired old man now your junk and you're
bored you're a mess
well I always hated slim grand harder he
killed my cousin but that was years ago
well we're slim grant who's slim grant
this is him an old friend of mr.
Calloway's you ain't no friend of mine
he's state marshal now out of Anna's
burg state marshal make a damn cousin
killer state marshal do they all right
I'll go get them great well wait for you
at Brandywine Trump just sober up and
start practicing otherwise this won't be
a book it'll be a memorial Ike me hey
what sounded like I'm a nobody I'm a
bear nobody locate and capture slim
grant really I gotta go to Anne's burg
where the hell is Anne's burg we're
gonna find that yeah whatever I gotta go
I gotta go see Dutch vanderlin first
we've been too much beating around the
bush here spending time with people that
aren't black Bell a bunch of [ __ ]
that's what I say come here
troll bait whoa wait I gotta pay my fine
excuse me I gotta pay my fine excuse me
I gotta pay my fine scuse me hello
everybody liked my whistling you like it
it's good tune I didn't know that you
were looking outside I just want to pay
my bounty there sir alright whoop a
schwa bass boom won't be boom be a
Scooby oh can I pull this pull this
rickshaw sound I can do no all right
fine then hello
up buddy Oh buddy and oof it eboo for
him let's get off dutch needs us the
boss needs us who was shooting on a horn
over there alright where are we headed
here we go back and forth back and forth
no matter what you do I was back and
forth yeah well we'll be there in a
second you need some sucked yes hello
okay okay all right I'll do what I can
okay all right then as weird
he week right after me I mean I'm
already helping what more do you need
yeah I'm all the help you need buddy and
the only help in this land that you're
gonna find
[Music]
okay Gary hello what's going on in here
what's going on
[Music]
sorry I had to do that oh look at that
I'm such a nice guy now you got it I'll
do my best can I drop him off your back
porch all right on a day's work ma'am
on the day's work glad I could be of
help please oh you know I don't need the
money I do this for helping people see
do I need to grab it the money - me - me
well easy come easy go all right come on
Bea why do you keep running off is it
because of the Gators in the swamp
probably ow ow ow Dutch needs us enough
distractions
all right Dutch I'll be right there hang
on I can't go very fast now I wonder if
they're actually are ghosts over there I
bet there are I bet that's a fun mission
but no time to explore that I got things
to do I got business to take care of
was right that way yeah it sounds about
right
either you get the deciding vote whoo
we take an insult and scurry off like
cockroaches a deal with business the
right way we don't need to take revenge
we hardly know the guy this ain't about
revenge Hosea Angelo Bronte don't mean
[ __ ] to me this is about the fact we are
planning to rob a bank in his town a
bank that he no doubt protects a town
where his men are gunning for us before
we do that we need to put him out of
commission tree there's always an easier
way ain't no easier way now I know his
type he is a vindictive little power
broker who rules by fear now we pull
that stunt in his cesspit of a town
we're doomed
you want to leave this place leave this
country we need that money just don't
feel good Dutch This Is It this is the
last job that we are ever gonna pull
before the year is out we are gonna be
harvesting mangoes into eating farmers
but we need seed capital and we need to
leave you know it I know forgive me if I
can't think too much about the mango is
it trust me Arthur fish business well
business is business
Angelo brontë stands between us and our
future you'll damned us all Arthur come
on
I've trust duck so far this one I've
trusted Dutch so far Dutchess never led
me astray okay you got a Dutch Dutch I
trust you
[Music]
I know hands pretty can attack Bronte's
mansion from the swamp catch him
off-guard he knows we survived the
trolley station so he'll be expecting
some kind of reprisal alright okay
make sense okay I never doubted you boss
I've always loved you from the start I
always knew that you would never lead us
astray boss huh you got it boss
all good points
you all seem to have forgotten how money
is made and responsible investment is
this 280 plan no I do this isn't a
prison camp forcing anybody to stick
together or we're not I know you're
right just feels like we're on borrowed
time again I mean you know Driscoll's
found us yeah we need to is the only one
left that ain't fair you are talking
like a charm I swear that woman is
poisoning him against me I've seen it
before
what's the problem here there ain't a
problem you think
Micah would question going after Bronte
no he'd say let's go I'm here heyno I've
been at your side for 20 years I know
I'm sorry yeah I think I think Dutch
might be losing it guys I think the
pressure of leadership is getting zone I
think he's really starting to feel it
and it's not going well because I mean
obviously I've been on his side the
whole time hello mr. Thomas if you met
Arthur Arthur Thomas is quite the
boatman he's gonna help us get close to
our prey fishing for catfish now my
friend
can I call in that favor what do you
need
you know Angelo Bronte well exactly we
need to make a social call we were
hoping you could row us in quietly one
evening around the back of his house if
anyone can I can't we'll pay you for
your trouble
if you bringing him trouble won't be no
trouble for me
my business partner Jules he's out on
the skiff I need to check with him
plus I need to check the traps won't you
come with me of course all right fine
whatever you say man whatever you say I
don't know why we're doing this we could
have just rode out right now take more
than a prehistoric reptile to scare you
Shirley
I just want to see you meet your match
when it comes to it an aging predator
with a big mouth this way come on this
way follow me
I like that swim through the swamp yeah
this ain't a good idea this is a word
you put that what you put the lantern
you shoved it into your side pocket okay
this seems like it'll be fine
this is gonna be fine I don't like those
bubbles
[Applause]
this is a terrible idea why would you be
going out by yourself what happens if I
go all allowed into the swap where are
we going what the hell this is are we
just okay with this just suddenly going
into the swamp look oh we're gonna go
check out some god
oh god everything is moist that's a
quite a turn from what we were gonna be
doing what okay that's why that that
crocodile was in there how can you tell
[Music]
I think we know what happened to Jules
it just so happens he got eaten by a
gator cuz that's what happens when you
do this I mean I can do that
let's open bot you first touch yeah
maybe it wasn't such a good idea to come
waiting out in the middle of the swamp
when you got a big pool going around I'm
assuming by Big Boi you don't actually
mean like a cow bowl you mean like a
like a gator bowl I don't know why you'd
call a gator a bowl but I don't like it
cuz it sounds bad holdin up hold up
[Music]
hello how are you good to see you you're
fast you're not so fast you're nice and
steady I like you
hey you're laughing keep laughing like
your cryptic answers mr. swamp man you
lose that I by the way into a staring
contest with a gator terrible idea you
know it's a bad idea game you know they
know they know what they're doing and
they're doing it in purposely not on
purposely and purposely they're doing an
end purposely just to mess with me
because that's what they want to do and
it's not okay no matter what way you
split it a not okay be not okay you got
a okay you got be not okay Oh
is that what I think it is is that what
I think it is well I seeing what I think
I'm seeing in that tree up there I see
what I think I'm seeing that can't be
good
that can't be good I think I see
something on three units
it's not good
okay all right Chum one day
oh boy
oh wait it's moving he's moving Jules
oh hi we're nearly 8 me where'd he go
it's it's up there what big Gator
biggest I ever saw big and nasty nothing
off the boat takes me over here
you must be Jews yes where is the boat
over there
maybe it's a good idea to be in the
water where's this monster swim off to
I'm thinking about what you think I
don't have a cannon I got pshew okay
stop I got a bad feeling about this one
Jules be careful hi Jules Jules be
careful there gotta be getting so sick
if they're always really now that
horrible swamp water they gotta get so
many illnesses fungal infections also
it's a bad stuff how they dealing with
that
yeah gross yeah why do we do that
[Music]
oh this - no friends of mine I'll
explain later
Jules you're gonna be dead twice as big
as I ever seen twice as angry - nonsense
maybe not so much nonsense oh that's not
a good idea it's not a good out here
yeah
and neither did you is just a myth Jules
Nepal oh not a good idea not a good idea
I want to get my guns out but it won't
let me huh there he goes he's going yeah
I'll go here we go
you still have your legs you still got
your legs Jules
oh no not your leg oh you're gonna get
such an infection well you'll have such
a fashionable peg leg oh oh
and
oh he's a big boy
please
dolls joel's hello do you have your legs
or your legs gone oh oh just be your leg
it didn't be your leg off put behind me
I want to look behind me what's behind
me I don't want to stop Oh God what ride
me what is it what is it what Oh God I'm
trying I'm trying boss I'm really try
why didn't you drive the boat closer ah
here you go here you go
no just that easier okay where oh that's
a big boy right on your snoot oh god
that's a big one
holy [ __ ]
hang on I need both this one whoa-ho-ho
you're too big Oh
there's still a lot of blood I'm putting
I'm squeezing I'm squeezing as hard as I
can squeeze I stopped the blade I think
you'll be okay if you don't get a fever
fever okay hang on I need Jolly Jack's
here I'm gonna hang out I gotta get my
tabacky come on come on come on come on
come on
oh come on
[ __ ] I can't tag him at all oh he's
getting closer a boy
we might be doomed sorry Jules
big ones it's late yeah I guess you
never outgrew Zanger kind of reminds me
of you are you know I don't think I've
ever seen you squid before Dutch yeah I
weren't the one squeeze yeah well you
weren't in the water with and this poor
boy was nearly dinner can we get some
help
Joel's been bitten oh my god that's a
monster out here he's been bitten but
he's alive
keep him warm feed him garlic foot
infection I'm smart I guess I'm at your
service anytime unique look Thank You
Tomas where can we find you just meet me
back here very good can one of you help
me put the bolt back half sure I'm gonna
head back to camp and placate the
irritable miss O'Shea who's causing for
trouble I'll collect the boys meet you
back here Arthur okay man kill some good
folks hurt a lot of people oh he
definitely lacks a certain charm I'll
see you soon
be safe you got muscles
yeah I'm aware of the monsters ooh'
loading screen no that's weird are we
just rolling right into the next mission
cuz I was a weird intro mission to this
relationship we got going on here but
I'll take it I guess I don't know I
don't know what we're doing but ooh I
haven't crafted or cooked in ages let me
see what I can make I don't even know
probably nothing right ah show craftable
absolutely dick ooh I could make special
ammo and that's it I get makes potent
snake oil perfect all right whatever
I've been collecting any ingredients I
guess that's what I get anyway all right
come on whoopee we gotta go it's time
it's time to put the hurt on mr.
whatever his name is no got him oh my
all the way down here why wouldn't I
just be near yeah whatever we're gonna
do this we're gonna do this right and I
ain't gonna be stopped by nobody on the
road that needs nothing sucked cuz all
my suckers being reserved for whatever
his name is
Oh Bronte Bronte come on come on bow get
it go go go
hello are you hey are you doing hey how
you doing hey how you doing okay alright
see it man I feel like this is gonna
lead to something big because Hosea I
said this before but it seems like more
and more recently Hosea is starting to
have this rift between not my business
not my business my business well what
was that I don't know but I need you
some of this there we go
maybe that's what just ran out over
there it seems like Hosea is gonna like
their confrontation that's gonna reach a
head at some point it's not gonna be
good for this family they've got going
over there
I mean my loyalties to Dutch like Arthur
loyal
that's what Tahiti's Louis let's get
going hey Bill you were a sharpshooter
in the cavalry weren't you what when we
get there maybe you could help with the
suppression fire I never said I was no
sharpshooter that's right what was it
the nation's most loyal latrine digger
wasn't that it thought and I fought one
so you always tell us tell me something
you could do with learning them Indians
were savages watch your mouth there boy
watch it only type of savage in these
parts a moonshine swilling pompous
inbred local Dutch I saw things out I
don't doubt you saw things bill but your
tiny little mind was too small to
comprehend what you saw what you saw was
people who lost everything to savagery
savagery of peasants failures come from
Europe to reap some full vengeance on
God's last creation
Justin why you boys gotta prepare for
I'm sorry I wasted my life trying to
teach you boys love you know I do
well even love a satyr you think we got
this don't you will never leave love
aside art it's all we got now what's
going on with Dutch something right
about Dutch that's is in a weird mood
just insulting insulting because of
young Bill Williamson like that thank
you
good I mean not that bill doesn't
deserve a little will sass every now and
then but yeah I just feel like it's a
bit much
what do we got going on here boys what
have we got going on oh I see okay all
right I'll take my spot okay no one help
me up my bad back and all that whatever
I guess I'll just get myself all right
what are we doing Dutch how we do
anything is good till you take the left
side if you see a shot you take it oh of
course
John of course let's go let's go get him
creep booty D pretty creepy dude ah this
has final confrontation
you got it buddy
you got a shot oh yeah oh did I get him
I don't know who's what that's a statue
all right come on come on come on oh
come on there we go
my hit that god damn filler waste all of
my [ __ ] [ __ ] that guy giving me the
business over here
I'm kind of woozy my shots are going all
over the place I don't know if that's
any effective beat in the swamp he was
coughing earlier I wonder if one of ours
has got a cold ear
all right in the dick my hat oh you're
gonna feel the wrath of the bear now I
don't even know where that went
you shooting all right let's go let's go
let's go come on Lenny don't you get
shot Lenny I'd miss you too much warm Oh
baby hi-yah oh what the
I meant to kick this boss sorry I meant
to kick this I'm meant to kick it meant
to kick it but it didn't work out that
way
can I get my gun out what the [ __ ]
there we go
where's he at where's my boy at
[Music]
bang sorry buddy
Wow what the [ __ ] where you come from
oh go out the window okay hello you
still alive buddy there we go
not in here were you at Bronte Dante
wait was that Bronte
oh wow name your price
name your price every man of a price
taking the Dutch yeah I guess you didn't
take your boy so I got him it's okay
Oh heavy big boy huh
just a little chat okay all right whoa
hey can you give me some covering fire
please thank you we got to go I'm going
oh don't worry I'll use him as a human
shield he ain't never gonna give to
nobody
hey how you doing hey you wanna maybe
once on this yeah I don't think they
want to take us to jail oh good Chozen
that's a lot of police
I'm getting good shots barely damn
now whatever I'm gonna head down
there we go come on guys let's go go go
go go go go go
where we go well oh he didn't bill and
we just got to take care of business
here I know you want dr. Lim but geez
oh no not Lenny no Lenny we got to get
Lenny out oh I thought Lenny wasn't
gonna make it because from where I'm
sitting you're the one deserving a pity
my friend all your man all your money
there weren't no match for a bunch of
bumpkins you have nothing you do nothing
mean nothing you stand for nothing me
I run a city even when the low catch up
to you you will die like nothing I am
this country you you you are what people
are running from I possess things that
you will never understand you don't even
possess your own men $1,000 to the man
who kills him and sets me free
what are you gonna say now no doubt the
law will find you already the dogs are
on the way oh yeah oh you're right
you are so right they are good at
smelling filth huh
so health has got to be
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mm-hmm
part that covers weakness that part yeah
no no well I do
did a nice I know it but it is us or him
a figure it might as well be him
[Music]
all right boss well done very assertive
boss quite reasonable very reasonable
even unbelievably reasonable
unreasonable bibley incredibly
reasonable very good okay well then I
guess let's go rob a bank why not why
not we've caused enough mayhem here
why not rob a bank sad on top of that of
course are you in the house Dutch
mandolin it's the right plan we've done
the work I've been in town looking
watching and and waiting I've tested it
as well as I can it's the right plan I
know I just well between you and me um
nervous
I suppose I suppose that's it never
nervous that's been my job all these
years I know you're sure certain not
certain it will be done but certain it
can be done and certain this is the only
way I see we can do it I've timed it out
more than once well you're the expert
Jill look the bank karen Tilly Abigail I
sent them all hey I'll say the same
thing there's no more than one armed
guard and the police
it's a city they're police but as far as
we can tell the patrols will all be
going this way when Abigail and I caused
the diversion that's the opportunity you
think Arthur I don't see we have a lot
of choice we linger around here we know
we're dead but the plan we got a decent
bunch we know how to fight the city cops
don't seem so tough as long as we move
I reckon doing it in the day with a
distraction
that's what Hosea say it's just good a
plan as any I think I agree
we do it at night there's the DRAM of
just getting into the bank can't do that
silently no pick us off our reason I
know I'm I'm just making sure every plan
is a good plan if we execute it properly
every problem we had was because we did
not execute properly even Blackwater
from my understanding you're right let's
Rob this bastard
everyone get some rest we ride out in
the morning all right all right
travel light I got a feeling Jose is
setting us up and within six weeks we're
living life anew in a tropical I don't
spend in the last of our days as banana
farmers let's get out of this
godforsaken place and go rob ourselves
up back I don't know I just got a bad
feeling about this just seems I don't
know some some don't feel right about
this
know that don't feel right that word so
devoid of imagination
how soon are we shipping out soon as we
get a passage organized go down to
Argentina to another around the Cape
what about the money in Blackwater we're
just gonna leave that behind forget that
it's gone you all talk like it's the
only goddamn money in the world we're
gonna take that more take it from the
people who take it from us
this isn't some hick town hundred dollar
operation this is a big city bank right
with security guards police mosaic is
done is reconnaissance we've been over
this the plan one last time Hosea and
Abigail draw out the police we go in
calm and fast God and Lenny secure the
front doors
Xavier takes the side exit Phil Micah
and Charles control the crowd me and
Arthur deal with the bank manager and
fault good all right that's enough talk
I got a bad feeling about this I got a
bad feeling about this
[Music]
and we'll all be seen heading in like
some posse country mr. feel right
nothing about this feels right
everything seems to be building there's
no way that this can just go perfectly
and I think Hosea was it was so
insistent but Dutch Dutch had doubts
whenever Dutch has doubts I know
something's about to go wrong act normal
Hey howdy neighbor hey how do you do how
do de howdy de lis do hey did Leo oh hey
how you doing how you doing hey how you
doing hey I'll buy a fray oh you're
throwing a nice blue on that building
over there hey have you ever seen a
building that blows I ain't never
haven't seen the building that blue or
red he's awfully nice you ever been to
the theater
there's a lady in a sprint fire out of
her vagina it's great it's wonderful you
ever seen that
Lemoine I thought we're in Santa knee
okay
oh she don't be then gentlemen robbing
thieves did any no crime at all folk
like this
they stole what this country could have
been
stay cool fellers back natural wait for
hosea to do his thing
this better work
looks like there's law over the other
side have a modicum of faith John will
you please as soon as we get out load
everything on to the wagon here okay all
right well here we go then just grab my
rifle real quick I want to make sure I
have like the good [ __ ] there we go
let's get the
Springfield rifle Zoey that's the good
Oh okey-dokey then
where's my mask cuz I don't have one
stupid
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
nice mask
[Music]
better go better go better go better go
man better go
better hurry
[Music]
all right let's do this let's do this we
gotta get in and out quick and going for
the big one first
[Music]
[Music]
fifty-four okay all right
[Music]
let's go okay well that was it just the
one get out here someone must have
squealed never should have gone after
Bronte Dutch mr. Milton let my friends
go or folks they are gonna get shot
unnecessarily your friend why would I do
that
come on Milton it's over no more
bargains no more deals mr. Milton this
is America you can always cut a deal
I've given you enough chances Oh
oh no I'm sorry I doubted or I could not
hit him where's my rifle give me my
rifle people about to get shot a whole
lot of people I feel like an [ __ ] try
your hat off now I'm gonna shoot your
head off sorry right in the eyeball
you did yeah god I feel so bad for
doubting him such an [ __ ]
BAM
Onoda that is a lot of people out there
by the way mailing these shots so got
the one behind ya hey let me switch to
my other one I can get a little few more
shots whoa whoa whoops
maybe you shouldn't be jiggling around
so much when you're trying to shoot
don't think about that point going not
enough they don't have enough
get down ducks Jesus that's a lot of
peeps I'm trying it's kind of hard
sometimes okay all right then I'll take
it just lottery Little Italy lot of the
water okay all right I guess I won't
fall over that that's fine
what'll be water history
[Music]
oh come on just get get over here
close enough
you got it boss I'm here now the
question now is who did rap it okay
there we go
sure that's out
oh shoot me who the hell knows I'm here
yeah whatever it don't matter I'm about
to put the hurt on these bastards I feel
so bad I doubted Hosea I thought Hosea
was gonna be the one that set us up I
don't know maybe he did where is it
oh I see you
[Music]
shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot what the
[ __ ] there you go
got you
[Music]
the others are trying to hold them off
doing what I can
[Music]
god
[Music]
hello Arthur we lost John killed
arrested I couldn't help well we better
go we'll be next what you think I reckon
me and let it try and find a way across
the roof so if you cover us sure all
right Lenny bottoms up one last time
Lenny
look out Lenny
[Music]
I'm heartbroken lady while any god damn
it you keep quiet and keep moving but
we're gonna be dead in the next few
minutes
follow me one at a time or you go next
I must beg John Moore sir
we can get in here
[Music]
I don't believe it I knew we were coming
just like your ferry job black boy ain't
nothing like that
what now I don't know I don't this whole
town is filled with cops well how long
we gonna stay here a few hours we go
back to camp they're gonna get every
last one of us I know they're gonna be
watching the roads I got it a boat what
you mean we stay here till nightfall
then we sneak on down to the docks we
get ourselves out of here yeah where any
place will do that's all I got we leave
we lie low we come back for the rest in
a few weeks I'm guessing it's that we
die out there
exactly everybody calm down
I mean I knew who's gonna be bad I just
didn't know we were gonna lose Lenny
I bet John and Abigail they definitely
Holloway knows they keep your heads down
I blamed Hosea like a tool god dammit
Hosea was a good one
always the loyal
of course then I hear voices
again
looks like they stopped we'll go through
the Train Arthur come on Bessie you
follow when it's clear yeah okay
hard to the left
get down and stay out of sight
I just don't know what to think of it my
mind is reeling is good like I knew it
was gonna be bad but I just didn't know
it's gonna be that bad and maybe I can
just stab this guy in the heart and
that'll make me feel a little bit better
about it I mean I knew cuz this is a
prequel I knew at some point John and
Abigail they're gonna betray just
because they want to live their normal
life but maybe they didn't betray you
I don't know if we're all gonna get out
of this alive I feel like more people
are gonna die before we're able to do
anything we got nowhere left to run do
we
there might be somewhere we can go but I
feel like we're really getting put in a
hole here and it's not gonna be a
happy-go-lucky next time we go because
we went to this house and it was like
things are looking up and things are not
looking up okay I know how to whistle I
know how to whistle there's one thing I
know how to do its whistle i whistle
Jenkins I know that whistle anywhere
that's a Jenkins war Oh which way you're
going which way you coming oh you stupid
idiots if you'd have gone the other way
you would have had a clear shot at me
stupid someone whistling it's some fool
whistling out here that old whistling
Jim I know it you shut up whistling Jim
uh-huh okay whatever you say boss things
are really looking up boss I like this
life when there's laws
I don't know they're watching for us
maybe maybe not well maybe they ain't
just waiting there for no reason
yeah let me think for a second I'll deal
with them how I can't kill all of them
silently so when they chase me you go
the other way what are you talking about
you heard what I said wait what you real
brave would you just Walton up to him
come on all right
weird okay beautiful acts just like
Walton right up past him yeah that's
that's definitely a good act
is he just gone is he gonna find us
again what's the deal
is he just gone well at least we got
some gold sure this boat I ain't going
it 280 by any chance I don't know John
Lenny Jose that wasn't good
so what we're gonna do now guess I'm
gonna introduce myself to the captain
give him some of this gold to security
silence and find out where we're heading
how do I look like a shift you know good
Kiner on the run from the law
ain't that the truth excuse me sir
hey forgive me a stowaway can I see the
captain please I come in peace
what a charmer what a charm in that
[ __ ] at least we got dressed nice for
this job well it's gonna take a little
more gold but I think we're gonna be
okay this captain he is a fine fella a
New Englander from the Cape the rest of
the ship is Frenchman they're heading
down to the islands taking some
Pennsylvania coal now apparently we're
going to be able to slip ashore in
northern Cuba in a couple of days
that's so apparently
what the hell what are we gonna do in
Cuba Dutch hold up for a while then
hurry back gather up the rest of our
family at least we got some money now
money and loyalty that you can do
whatever you please so you reckon
they'll follow us to Cuba
like Colonel Waxman on a jolly I highly
doubt it I reckon we hold ourselves to
ourselves and this is done and dusted
let's hope so
ain't no sailor but that cloud look like
good news to you
[Music]
it's a sperm hooks off now you're
talking about the little white cloud
they're not the big big dark ominous
cloud this is taken of course everything
had to be bad
oh boy what's happening now whoa did he
get crushed or did separated as a
separator the hell happened what the
hell happened why does it sound like a
war out there what is happening at least
I look good oh [ __ ] that's not good
[Music]
no no oh that's a bad idea
oh I hate it
what the hell is happening
[Music]
oh good now I'm gonna play castaway here
all this has been leading up to some
kind of island survival simulator now I
got a craft stuff I got a build a heart
I got to cut down some trees there's
gonna be candles everywhere it's gonna
be horrible but fun this is how the
forest is that was just a big opening
sequence for a bigger game wait how big
is my beard right now how long was i
adrift for
wait a minute this is a bunch of kelp
stuck on my face oh I don't feel so good
this is where's the mangoes somebody cut
me up a pineapple anybody good I'm gonna
build Dutch out of coconuts and I'm
gonna give Dutch the tits he always
deserve to have and then Dutch and I are
gonna make a lovely family you're on the
island all by ourselves
come on coconut ditch we're gonna have
ourselves a good time
hello anybody maybe but I'm very lonely
already I'm dazed and confused but
already I've slipped steadily in the
madness anybody Dutch Dutch that's all
right I guess not we're just gonna keep
zooming out
oh there I am hey my beard is big ok
then here there
at least my hair is still nice and
pomaded we're just doing this story is
it taken take it a to complete 360 oh
boy
and Arthur dies trapped on an island
alone and scared and afraid
oh here we go oh now we're better okay
alright well it's lovely
whatever it is beautiful just goddamn
gorgeous okay huh this is where I get
abducted by aliens maybe maybe some kind
of alien with something to do with me
lovely water physics you got going on
there definitely has circumstance I
never expected this game to go in but
oddly enough I'm kind of okay with it oh
this is where I find out that we're
actually in West world there's like the
island for West world and all this has
just been a horrible West world thing
that's what all this is was okay
whatever animal that is I don't like
okay Oh goodbye this is so weird
this is so weird I love it though and
it's just weird up there I go and I'm
dead oh that's weird I'm dead but my
eyes are still moving that's so creepy
and disconcerting maybe they're all
right well you know I wouldn't have to
keep getting back up if I did if I could
just stop falling over oh boy that is an
island Wow okay tap tap water MA oh okay
how many chapters are there how many
chapters are there oh I got a trophy
okay Wow
okay weird so I have any food I bet not
smoke smoke smoke
I like smoke smoke good hello somebody
get washed up here john marston hello
wait who is this
this can't be there's no way there's no
way there's no way no way
there is a miracle he does it goddamn
miracle have something to drink have a
drink somebody give a goddamn drink we
got you we got that is the craziest
thing I've ever seen
totally unrealistic but I love it
nonetheless
Xavier asked a local it's a old sugar
plantation Island second island east of
Cuba is it anywhere near Australia long
way I guess yes you're okay what next I
don't know oh well next I guess we're
gonna get shot this is quite a welcome
who are you send your port for we are no
one what's your name Aidan O'Malley
that's so what are you doing mr.
O'Malley surviving we were lost at sea
in the storm that's oh no I'm in the
habit of looking like this is all of
this really necessary
we got enough troubles around here right
now mr. O'Malley I've taken a chance on
a bunch of bag of bones behave
yourselves and no harm will befall you
okay all right okay I guess this is
where we are now
okey-dokey then
[Music]
whoa weird turns this is taken what the
hell's going on Levi Simon senior
overseer for Alberto pasa they run the
third most productive sugar plantation
in the northern Caribbean of course
where there's money to be made there's
trouble what sort of trouble oh the
usual sort people wanting what ain't
theirs and others telling them to take
it I don't get you
labor troubles and other thieves and
pirates looking to disrupt our ways of
working how very upsetting for you
not half as upsetting as it'll be for
them mr. foucha has a lot of very
powerful friends I will bet that he does
bunch of Haitian pirates won't frighten
him
you strung up in the streets soon enough
and we seem like Haitian pirates to you
mr. Simon you seem like someone or other
we was headed to Tahiti he was doing the
scenic route as soon as I know exactly
who you are you'll be free meantime
you'll not starve
estos hombres a la cárcel who da cunha
grupo de cucarachas there's a cappuccino
kirtan tahrir que hagan despair eraser
todos welcome to Guam ah gentlemen
you'll excuse me yeah okay goodbye well
I don't know what do you think yeah but
they can't find out who we are I think
they can hear us maybe one of them
speaks English well anyway I'll just do
the awkward shuffle along
that's what we're doing then okay
all right is it busy
sorry I just exploded didn't slide in my
head oh but they got them chained and
lashed but they don't look too dangerous
okay and off we go then fight boss yo
this sure is fun
I like scooting on my footsies I sure
like it I like the way the rocks in the
beach really scrape up my Tootsie's
you're like when I walk hips forward
like this boss
I like it when you pull me along boss
give me a good dog
[Laughter]
you know I don't need to walk this close
to you boss but I just can't help but
feel awfully intimate after surviving
though hey boss I'm gonna pass yeah come
on what are we doing err why you all
rubbing your necks in synchronicity oh
well that's not good everybody will put
in a pity
oh well BAM
oh you're still alive
dick got him that's me that's me boss I
do good work all the time you can always
count on me me reinforcements no get
Xavier
[Music]
[Applause]
right
well here we go I don't know what side
we're fighting on but hey they gave me a
gun so I guess I can't be too unhappy
boink
at go bye-bye coin at go bye-bye along
with head oh he's dead
push you up a push-up I'm doing great
for my hair boss you are so brave okay I
don't know why I'm supposed to push up
on them but I'm gonna listen to boss and
we're gonna push up on him there we go
push it okay he's dead alright here we
go
who's okay alright
you're not dead
well that was association come on we got
caught up in something serious over here
and we are way out of the West now what
we are exactly but okay I went to be on
Hecht you front end vanderlin these
drowned rats or mica bill North okay
okay
who's that well be desperate to find you
we must be very careful so who is this
Foose or a tyrant driven by nothing but
power and greed our only purpose is to
work ourselves to death to make him rich
Leon wants the people to stand up to
fusa but most are too afraid and you I
am NOT from here I bring things in and
off the islands behind coral fossils
back let's say let's guess the moment
down there is aqua dolce forces compound
the sugar cane these poor men killed
themselves farming gets processed in
that factory they're little more than
slaves shipped in from other islands a
group escaped yesterday into the jungle
hoping to find a way back to their homes
now full-size men are out hunting them
down that old fort Cinco Torres
my men and I use that that they hide out
when we are here come on I know
somewhere you men can arrest
not exactly a hideout when they can see
the building from their factory only one
who can enjoy book for you all right I
need something in the table of course Oh
God with that what happened to my camera
how long now
hey wait a minute oh I think my camera
died it old standard let's play
he will lead you right there thank you
the workers are somewhere in the jungle
hopefully we can get to them before fusa
dose of course gentlemen well goodbye
this is a tropical paradise so far it
ain't up to much
I'll go scope the entrance to that cake
Fork sir I need to get some rest
well you're right we all need to relax
what a mess I'm so sorry boys get some
sleep
Dutch mica guard this spot we'll do some
more scouting carefully hmm God what a
weird situation this has turned into
[Music]
anyway welcome back to the standard
let's play I think that's gonna wrap it
up for this episode unless they've got
even more story to tell but now it looks
like we finally settled into our new
location here in Guam ah in the middle
of a civil war kind of like how in the
first game there was the the the Mexican
war that they were dealing with over
there but anyway thank you so much for
watching even though you can't see my
face know how grateful I am that you're
joining me for this adventure so
there'll be more episodes of this coming
at you soon thank you everybody so much
for watching take care of yourselves and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye